so
[Applause]
good morning friends it's my great
pleasure to join you to launch rishi
sunet's campaign to be the next leader
of our party and the next prime minister
of our great country
now i know
that rishi has got what it takes
he's got what it takes to provide the
leadership that we need to steer the
country through tough economic times
in the pandemic he put the package
together that saved 12 million jobs and
thousands upon thousands of businesses
and of course it's only because
he got the economy back on track after
cobit that in this global fight against
inflation we could take the measures
that we've been able to to protect the
most vulnerable struggling to make ends
meet and there's more we know there's
more we've got to do
now
you know during this contest you may
just hear
one or other candidate talk about tax
cuts
just remember this
while others talk the talk
rishi this month delivered the biggest
tax cut for working people in a decade
and he did it because
he's a true conservative imbued by his
parents and his grandparents who first
came over here in the 1960s
imbued with the values of enterprise
hard work and family
rishi's values are our values
and he's always had the courage of his
convictions and i remember back when we
had the referendum in 2016. he was one
of the first ones out of the traps as a
young new member of parliament a
backbencher with all the pressure on him
at the time
and he immediately put his colors to the
mast and not just that he immediately
started thinking about how he could
grasp the opportunities of brexit
in 2016 he wrote the seminal pamphlet on
three ports five years later as
chancellor he delivered the first ones
rishi is someone who makes things happen
and
my friends just as we need to be honest
about the economic challenges we face i
think we've also got to be really honest
about the political predicament that we
face
that's the threat of a socialist
government propped up by the lib dems
and the snp
and we know their price too there's no
secret about it one referendum on
electoral reform the other a referendum
to break up this great united kingdom of
ours
that threat is real and we will face it
in just two years time so there's no
time to learn on the job
we all got to come together we got to
unite to win and i mean that right
through the party from our brilliant
local councillors the amazing grassroots
that we've got the people that knock on
the doors that deliver the leaflets
right the way through the conservative
parliamentary party and across the
cabinet with one team and we will stand
or fall together
but to make the very best of this
excellent exciting inspirational
aspirational agenda that we've got to
unite this brilliant conservative team
we need a leader who can win
and the reality is that polling shows
only rishi can beat labour
only rishi can win with the support of
lee voters and remain voters
only rishi can win in the north and in
the south in the blue wall and the red
wall
he's got the economic leadership he's
got the values to bring us all together
and he's the only one that can win
ladies and gentlemen let's make him our
next leader let's make him our next
prime minister please welcome rishi
sumac
we need to have a grown-up conversation
about where we are
how we got it and what we intend to do
about it
it's a conversation for those of us
gathered here in this room today
and the conservative party more widely
but above all it's a conversation we
need to have
with the british people
and it starts
with being honest with each other that
matters
because the decisions we make in the
coming days and weeks will set a course
that will determine whether the next
generation of british people
inherit a stronger and more confident
nation
the conservative party was elected with
a large majority so it falls to us to
decide who carries the flag forward in
this parliament
but it is not a decision that should be
made behind closed doors with no input
from the public
from the beginning i wanted this
campaign
to be more than just a case for my
leadership i also wanted it to be a
moment where the party and the country
came together
before i talk about the campaign
i want to say something about how
we got here
i want to talk
about boris johnson
as candidates to replace him we owe it
to the british people who elected boris
as prime minister in 2019 to explain why
he is leaving office
there is something wrong about a process
that sees a sitting prime minister
replaced while the people doing the
replacing pull the curtains and act like
it's nobody's business but theirs
it's everybody's business
so let me tell you how i see it
boris johnson is one of the most
remarkable people i've ever met
and
whatever some commentators may say
he has a good heart
did i disagree with him frequently
is he flawed
yes
and so
are the rest of us
was it no longer working yes and that's
why i resigned
but let me be clear
i will have no part in a rewriting of
history that seeks to demonize boris
exaggerate his faults or deny his
efforts
we know his achievements breaking the
brexit deadlock
winning a stunning election victory
rolling out a world-class vaccination
program and standing up for a free
ukraine when other leaders were still
wringing their hands
some people might advise that i should
avoid saying all of this in case it
alienates people but that wouldn't be
honest
if telling you what i think positive and
negative cost me the leadership so be it
since i declared a few short days ago
the response has been well overwhelming
beyond my imagination
thousands of volunteers have reached out
to join our campaign because they have
heard
a message
of change
i'm running a positive campaign focused
on what my leadership can offer our
party
and our country
i will not engage
in the negativity that you may have seen
and read in the media
if others wish to do that then let them
that's not who we are
we can be better
because i look across the field of
candidates and i see colleagues and
friends
i see people i admire and respect people
with exceptional qualities i want to say
to all of them
we are still part of the same
conservative family and when this
election is over we're going to work
together for the british people
but before that we have to resolve some
disagreements incredibly important
disagreements about the nature and depth
of our challenges that the country faces
and the right response to them
a pandemic that all but broke the world
economy a war in mainland europe and
most visibly at home now a global spike
in inflation that has risen to levels
not seen since the 70s and 80s
when confronted with challenges so
fundamental
the right place to start is with your
values
and my values
traditional conservative values are
clear
hard work
patriotism
fairness
a love of family
pragmatism
but also
an unshakable belief that we can build a
better future
values
values that compel me to say it is
completely unacceptable in this country
that too many women and girls do not
enjoy the same freedom most men take for
granted in feeling safe from assault and
abuse
that our natural environment is an
inheritance we preserve and protect for
future generations
and that at a time
of rising global instability we have a
responsibility to the world to provide
leadership that is why as chancellor i
prioritize record funding for the armed
services who represent the best of our
country and do heroic work
but as vital as values are
they are not enough
we need to have a grown-up conversation
about the central policy question that
all candidates have to answer in this
election
do you have a credible plan to protect
our economy and get it growing
my message to the party and the country
is simple
i have a plan to steer our economy
through these headwinds
we need a return to traditional
conservative economic values and that
means
honesty
and responsibility
not fairy tales
[Music]
it is not credible to promise lots more
spending and lower taxes
i had to make some of the most difficult
choices of my life as chancellor in
particular how to deal with our debt and
borrowing after covid
i have never hidden away from those i
certainly won't pretend now the choices
i made and the things i voted for were
somehow not necessary
and whilst that may be politically
inconvenient for me it is also the truth
as is the fact that once we've gripped
inflation i will get the tax burden down
it is a question of when
not if
and i will achieve this because i have a
clear plan to get our economy growing
quickly we need to implement the radical
reforms i set out as chancellor to the
way businesses are taxed to make our
country the best place in the world to
invest more train more and critically to
innovate more
we need to use the new freedoms brexit
has given us and the new mentality it
can give us to reform the mass of
regulations bureaucracy and constraints
that too often get in the way
we need to build a new consensus on
people coming to our country
yes to hard working talented innovators
but crucially control of our borders
and we need to transform the performance
and productivity of our public services
by integrating technology empowering
good leaders and caring much more about
what actually works than what sounds
good
i believe we can build a better smaller
21st century government that helps to
support growth and countries around the
world seek to emulate
now if we do all of this
we will get our economy growing quickly
again not just for a short burst but
sustainably for generations to come
this is the surest path to tax cuts that
work to keeping our schools and nhs
strong to properly funding our armed
forces and keeping our country safe
so that is my plan
tackle inflation
grow the economy and cut taxes it is a
long-term approach that will deliver
long-term gains for families and
businesses across the united kingdom
i am prepared to give everything i have
in service to our nation
to restore trust
rebuild our economy and reunite the
country
i want to have a grown-up conversation
where i can tell you the truth
a better future is not given
it is earned
that is why i am standing to be the next
leader of the conservative party and
your prime minister
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thanks everyone
i think we're going to take some
questions both from the audience and a
few from the media so apparently the
first question is roberto roberto where
might you be hi hi i'm roberto i'm a
local counselor here in london
and a party volunteer rishi we've got
some real challenges ahead as you
mentioned inflation the war in ukraine
recovering from covet
how are you going to take us through all
of that and bring us back together as a
party and as a country
roberto well first of all thank you for
what you do locally and you're right we
do have some big challenges ahead of us
and i think if we want to start dealing
with them the first thing we have to be
is honest that they exist we have to
recognize the scale of the challenges we
face to be honest with the country about
that we can't pretend that they're easy
or that they're not there
and what it requires is serious
leadership to tackle them and that's
what i believe i can offer i believe
that we can restore trust we can rebuild
our economy and protect the most
vulnerable as we do so and we can
reunite the country and i know i can do
it with your help so thank you
right next from the media we've got
chris
chris mason from the bbc chris hi good
morning chris mason bbc news day after
day so many of your colleagues have
sought to demolish your record as
chancellor do you have the stomach for
what's to come
[Laughter]
well well i'm standing here today
surrounded by friends and colleagues
that's what gives me the optimism the
confidence to do this i i want to run an
entirely positive campaign as i said in
my speech i have enormous respect for my
colleagues my friends who are running in
this contest and most important thing to
remember is we're all part of the same
conservative family and when this is
said and done we're going to come
together i'm going to get back to
serving the british people and i'm
looking forward to doing that with them
all right next we've got carl from itv
carl where are you
i'm going to go next is
you've painted a picture of yourself as
being as loyal as you could have been to
boris johnson
but really if you didn't believe that
you were less flawed than boris johnson
you wouldn't be standing here would you
can you just spell out why you thought
it wasn't working and you had to quit
well carl you you received my
resignation letter where i explained
that but it wasn't an easy decision it
was an incredibly difficult and sad
decision because i've worked closely
with boris and loyally for over almost
two and a half years and you know when
it came to it though as i've said in my
letter there were just some things that
were becoming too difficult uh for me to
to keep working with him on but you
heard what i said in the speech about my
views on boris and i meant them 100
but you suggested that he was no more
than anyone else
i think we're we're all flawed i think
there's not a single leading politician
who can stand here and say that we're
perfect you know all of us have our
strengths and weaknesses and you know
our job is to talk about what we can
offer the country as candidates
positively and optimistically that's
what i'm doing today i'm sure my
colleagues will do the same as i said
we're all part of the same family we
should be proud of the things that we've
done that have made a difference to this
country i am i'm proud to have been part
of a government that did all those
things that i talked about and i'm proud
that the prime minister provided the
leadership to do those things
okay uh thank you richie sunak you've
just stood here and said boris johnson's
a remarkable person you don't want
history to demonize him but the fact is
uh that the parties just ousted him on
the basis of conduct probity and causing
division
and here you are and i have to put it to
you that you have a police fine over
partygate and there have been questions
too
over your very wealthy family
avoiding paying millions of pounds in
tax due to your wife being a non-dom
taxpayer now that i know arrangement has
changed but that was until very recently
and i have to say you're an utterly
corrosive figure in the parliamentary
party for a big chunk of it so i put it
to you
i i have i i'm sorry but there are
there are many in the party uh that do
not want you to be prime minister you
know that so i put it to you
that you're not a clean
come from you quickly and then misty
will get mad at me but i'm going to be
late for these next days
no thank you you're standing to be the
next prime minister you can take a
couple of questions from some
journalists um
dominic cummings has been openly
campaigning to make you the prize
dominic cummings has been openly
campaigning to make you the prime job in
downing street for him in your
administration and one more if i may
give away i've only got you for a little
while last week the prime minister
pledged to uh
to increase defense spending to 2.5 of
gdp by the end of this decade will you
continue with that vow in office if you
win and if so why did you ignore
repeated warnings this year
that britain will miss the crucial nato
target of two percent of defence
spending okay you know two excellent
questions harry so thanks for asking
them so look firstly on dominant
comments dominic cummings said that has
had absolutely nothing to do with this
campaign and will have absolutely
nothing to do with any government that
i'm privileged to lead
and for the record i have not
communicated with dominic cummings since
the day that he left downing street so i
just want to make sure that's clear and
thank you for asking it and look on on
defense spending you know what what can
i say so first of all i view our nato
target as a
floor and not a ceiling so that's
something that i can absolutely commit
to
and also the most important thing to
know is our defense spending is already
forecast to grow to around two and a
half percent over time as a result of
the investments that we're making in
things like our future combat air system
and orcas and and others but the way i
think about it is not to think about
defense spending through arbitrary
targets because actually what's the most
important thing it's making sure that
this country is protected against the
threats that it's based so my approach
to defence spending will be threat based
and that's not about an arbitrary number
that's making sure that we make the
investments to protect ourselves to keep
ourselves safe and if you look at my
record i was a chancellor that put in
place the largest increase in defence
spending since the end of the cold war i
was a chancellor that oversaw over 2
billion pounds of military support to
ukraine it's a record that i'm very
proud of
thank you all very much
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yes
you